so the big news this weekend of course
was that donald trump was
acquitted in his second impeachment
trial no president has ever been
impeached twice donald trump has been
impeached
twice and now in both subsequent
impeachment trials remember the house
impeaches the senate tries
trump has been acquitted in both trials
and to convict on impeachment you need
two-thirds
vote to convict in the senate all 100
senators being present that means that
on saturday
67 senate votes were needed and they got
only 57 that's all 50 democrats
including newly minted democratic
senators
john ossoff and rafael warnock radical
liberal
raphael warnock that guy remember him
that includes the two of them
reminding us of the importance of those
january 5th
primaries getting to 50 and then seven
republicans
voting to convict those were richard
burr
bill cassidy susan collins lisa
murkowski mitt romney ben sasse and pat
toomey
we will talk about why those seven a
little bit later
but 57 is not 67 simple math tells us
that
and so donald trump did end up acquitted
now
not a surprise we knew all along that it
would go this way
but one of the really wacky things that
happened is that
senate minority leader no longer
majority leader
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
voted not guilty
and then immediately took the floor to
give a defiant and detailed speech
about how donald trump did incite
the riot and did incite the violence
and the insurrection and we're going to
look at some clips here
mitch mcconnell moments after voting not
guilty
making as good a case as the house
impeachment managers about donald
trump's guilt
about donald trump's responsibility
about donald trump's culpability for the
insurrection and the riots
that took place on january 6th but he
voted not guilty let's get into it
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
no question about it the people who
stormed this building believed
they were acting on the wishes and
instructions
of their president
and having that belief was a foreseeable
consequence of the growing crescendo
of false statements conspiracy theories
and
reckless hyperbole which the defeated
president kept shouting into the largest
megaphone on planet
earth the issue
is not only the president's interpret
language
on january 6.
it is not just his endorsement of
remarks
in which an associate urged quote trial
by combat
it was also the entire manufactured
atmosphere of looming catastrophe
the increasingly wild myths myths
about a reverse landslide election
that was somehow being stolen
some secret coup i i mean
a total and complete indictment of
donald trump's actions
but so why vote not guilty mitch
and hear mitch mcconnell explains
if president trump were still in office
i would have carefully considered
whether the house managers
proved their specific charge
by the strict criminal standard
the president's speech probably was not
incitement however
however in the context of impeachment
the senate might have decided this was
acceptable shorthand for the reckless
actions that preceded
the riot
but in this case the question is moot
because former president trump
trump is constitutionally not eligible
for conviction now this is a close
question
no doubt donald trump was
the president when the house voted
though not when the house chose to
deliver the papers
and there is basically the explanation
mcconnell
going on to say that since the
punishment for
impeachment is removal from office
and donald trump is out of office that
this was not a proper
impeachment they cannot convict as a
matter
of procedure is what mitch mcconnell is
arguing now
in saying that mitch mcconnell misses
a number of important details the first
detail is that a week ago today
last monday we had a full day of debate
about whether the trial was okay
and whether the senate had jurisdiction
to try a former president and they voted
and settled that issue 56-44
but mcconnell won't let it go the the
idea of how the senate works is that
as a body the senate dealt with that
question
it wasn't unanimous mitch mcconnell was
one of the 44
who believed that the senate did not
have that right but as a body
and again if you want to say how you
know the senate is not a legal body so
why is the senate
even voting on the constitutionality of
the proceedings
they chose to and they decided that yes
56 to 44 they can do the trial meaning
if they determine the person did what
they're accused of doing
they can say guilty but mcconnell
doesn't care so mcconnell is using an
already adjudicated issue to say that's
why i voted not guilty
second it's not just removal from office
that is being debated and voted on and
is the punishment it is also
barring trump from running again a
punishment which
could be met it out but mitch mcconnell
chooses not to mention that and only
focus on removal from office so
a truly pathetic attempt by mitch
mcconnell to play both sides
he gets his not guilty vote in and
appeases the trumpists
he denounces the actions of trump
appeasing the more
sane republicans and on he goes as he
has been doing for year after year after
year
impeachment manager madeline dean
noticed
how bizarre of a situation it was mitch
mcconnell voting not guilty
and then speaking 90 about why trump is
guilty and then mentioning but he's out
of office so i had to vote not guilty
take a look at this madeline dean clip
it was powerful
to hear the 57 guilties
and then it was puzzling to hear and see
mitch mcconnell stand and say not guilty
and then minutes later
stand again and say he was guilty of
everything
history will remember that statement of
speaking out of two sides of his mouth
now different
republican senators have been citing
different reasons for why they voted not
guilty most of them
some some taking the mitch mcconnell
approach
about procedure others saying trump
didn't really do the incitement
but really it's just political
expediency because when you look at the
republicans who did vote to convict
you start to get a picture of what's
going on here lisa murkowski knows she
doesn't need to be on trump's side
to win in alaska so she's free to do
whatever she wants
ben sass has never really cared about
party approval
and he's taken hits from the republican
party and he doesn't seem to care so
that's ben sasse cassidy is in louisiana
where there are no
standard party primaries he doesn't have
to worry about that
mitt romney okay after the meeting where
he had the frog's legs
and thought maybe trump would make him
secretary of state after that
romney really hasn't cared and we know
he doesn't need donald trump's support
in utah because utah republicans are
some of the most anti-trump republicans
in the country
pat toomey and richard burr they're
retiring so they don't care
and then susan collins has this more
moderate constituency
in maine so these aren't coincidences
that
these are the seven republicans
who voted to convict these were not
seven republicans who believed trump was
guilty and 43 who did not
this was probably several dozen
republicans who believe trump was guilty
seven of which seven of whom uh
have particular circumstances that allow
them to actually vote their conscience
rather than what we saw
for many republicans and of course you
have many republicans who genuinely
believe that this was all
you know unnecessary and unfair and all
of that i'm guessing
well i don't know which ones those are i
guess ted cruz would be one maybe josh
hawley
some others so uh that's that trump
acquitted
57 to 43 a major a majority saying
guilty
but needing that two-thirds vote trump
acquitted and let's now get into some of
the other
interesting moments from the last day of
the trial the last couple of days of the
trial
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video